[Music]
the Special Air Service regiment or SAS
air was a special forces unit of the
Australian Army this group was modeled
on the British SAS informed back in 1957
both units share the motto who dares
wins this organization has taken part in
a number of operations in and around
Australia while also providing
counterterrorism support a number of
projects have included other countries
such as Borneo East Timor Vietnam
Somalia Iraq and Afghanistan after
observing the operations of the British
Special Air Service during the Malayan
emergency in the 1950s the Australian
Army decided to raise its own SAS unit
and on the 25th of July 1957 it was
established within this unit that
consists for Sabre squadrons they
operate globally in warfare surveillance
and humanitarian aid along with
peacekeeping initiatives across the
world the SAS our regards themselves of
having very high entry standards and the
selection and to the Richmond is
considered to be the most demanding of
any entry tests in the Australian Army
part of the role requires working with
small teams for extended periods and
often without support from the outside
because of this they are categorically
selected for their ability to work in a
closed and isolated environment as a
team rather than just as individuals
after the reactivation of Team rainbow
in 2015 to SAS our operators were
recruited to bring their skills and
expertise to assist in the fight against
terrorism on a global scale
[Music]
you
three lakh and mozzie in pursuit
right laughter boy
taury tell you ferrous code named
gridlock is an attacking operator and
team rainbow even from an early age
gridlock was fascinated and working with
engines and enjoyed competing in
robotics tournaments as the eldest of
five is of no surprise she has always
demonstrated strong leadership potential
she possesses clear vision as courageous
has integrity honesty humility and
absolute focus which can be seen
throughout her career with a background
in mechanics which was heavily
influenced by her father who worked as
an aircraft mechanic in the military
originally gridlock joined the
Australian Army Reserve to further
expand to her mechanical engineering
skills where she was also given the
opportunity to access the very best
equipment after graduating from
University she joined the Australian
Defence Force which he further honed her
mechanical abilities her unique set of
skills unsurprisingly make her an
invaluable member of the SSR Mobility
platoon as she exhibits a wide range of
expertise in a number of weapons she has
adaptive intelligence collecting and as
an exceptional body guard her ability to
readjust her unexpected circumstances
and remain calm and dangerous situations
has meant that she's been offered a
number of elite positions but she has
repeatedly turned them down gridlock has
a let's get on with that attitude and
doesn't shy away from hard work yet
always manages to find humor in every
situation this is likely to be part of
the reason why she turns down the
promotions as the higher levels can
often require a certain amount of
discussion and politics that hindered
her ability to jump in and get things
done plus she jokes that there's just
too much paperwork gridlock was awarded
the national emergency middle for a part
in saving firefighters she was part of a
daring rescue of trekked firefighters
after her father died she and her mother
discovered the family farm was and did
gridlock took the lead rallying her four
siblings and extended cousins while
using her army salary to save the farm
gridlock isn't afraid of responsibility
and a desire to look out for a family
extends to how she interacts with the
team gridlock uses a gadget that winter
on deploys barbed mats capable of
slowing down and hurting enemies the
design is portable and when activated
deploys a hexagonal cluster of spikes
once deployed it can replicate and
spread over a large area this feature
enables gridlock to use the obstacle to
reshape the map and control an area
effects on the enemy includes slowing
them down and causing damage when
stepped on
[Music]
it's a quiet year mm-hmm
it's really really really
[Music]
[Music]
MECs goose code named mozzie was
defending operator and team rainbow
mozzie grew up is the middle child in
his family naturally having him placed
in a situation where he struggled to be
heard or noticed which is likely to
explain the more showman side of his
personality he jokes that his parents
paid more attention to him the moment he
engaged in extreme sports like freestyle
mountain biking dune buggy racing and
the occasional hand gliding he recalls
the moment where his mum completely lost
it after he told her that he did
skydiving with dirt bikes after year 10
mozzie applied to enter the Australian
Defence Force Academy later working in
combat and security he joined an
infantry regiment that incorporated dirt
bikes and all-terrain vehicles in their
reconnaissance operations
mazi excelled in land navigation and
became the two-wheeler expert in raids
scouting and convoy operations mozzie
takes the english language to a new
level
he has reached greater heights than most
with a creative approach to the use and
overuse of profanities in his general
day-to-day speech in communication it is
said that he uses vulgarity to make up
for his physical stature in an attempt
to appear more intimidating observations
indicate that he is quite sensitive
about his height
following operation catalyst mozzie was
hand-picked to join the Special Air
Service regiment as long as he passed
selection and kept his mouth shut
his specialized off-road skillsets and
quick thinking were highly prized
although was seen as a little reckless
he later received the national
emergency' medal for saving firefighters
during the espérance
bush fires mozzie is a calculated
daredevil who loves testing upcoming
military stealth bikes but he says there
is no bigger honor and being asked to
join Team rainbow he's a speed demon not
just on his bike but also with how he
processes information by the time others
have done assessing a situation he has
already considered the feasibility of a
particular course of action having
weighed up the pros and cons and has
started his bike the 2nd Z saving are
precious but he's a troublemaker in
spirit and a showman at heart mozzie is
equipped with a launcher that releases
BOTS that electron to nearby enemy
drones hijacking their controls the
launcher called pests are tiny
four-legged BOTS that can be used to
target a single drone or deployed into
an area to prevent access by a drone
when launched the pest latches on to the
nearest enemy drone and covers its
camera but then initiates an override
sequence to hack the drone and give
control to mozzie
mazi and gridlock have a long history
having first met in high school at robot
world competitions and then again during
army training they've been a team ever
since individually they're assets to
remember but together they dominate both
consistently demonstrate creativity and
skills under pressure on their own
mazi and gridlock perform exceedingly
well but together they pull off some
amazing even here brain stunts that
would make even the most Stern of
commanders crack a smile if they were
successful of course like their
operation during the espérance bushfires
these two specialists create a
remarkable balance seldom seen between
two operators hey guys thank you very
much for watching I actually quite like
these two they're a little different
among the rest of the team and they do a
good job of embracing some of the more
classic stereotypes of Australian
culture when one of the first things I
read was I'm not here to [ __ ] spiders I
knew I was in for a treat anyway thanks
again and I'll catch in the next one
Cheers